barium is one of the is the heaviest
stable alkaline earth that's the same
group to the same one this magnesium
beryllium and so I believe that it
wasn't labeled when they picked it up on
the ground but this is an example of
barium sulfate it's a very heavy mineral
and barium absorbs x-rays quite strongly
so when people are ill and the doctors
need to x-ray their insides you can't
look at the inside of somebody's stomach
or throat easily by x-rays but if you
give them a drink of barium which is
called barium meal or a barium enema
depending which hole you put it in then
the tube or their gut becomes opaque to
the x-rays and so then you can image
them quite easily and if there's some
nasty hole or something then it appears
much more easily